hello and good morning or good evening
wherever whenever you're watching this
today we're excited to share with you a
new product announcement that has been
years in the making my name is Gil
Aquilani and I'm an engineering director
in GCP security where 18 confidential
prepared with me today is not a porter
the lead product manager for complex
computing later we'll be joined by
morgan Akers director of data protection
at JP Morgan Chase so Nelly let's start
from the beginning what is the data
protection problem our customers are
facing today Thank You Galan really
really great to have you here with me
today so data protection problem is very
important problem for customers and
again all this time they had and
understood how to deal with this problem
the data customers collected was under
DITA centers and they know who accessing
this data we had really good physical
perimeter across this data they can
control not only access but also policy
that can be applied to this data and
they use it they are responsible to
protect the data so no they gain big
news there everything is what is
familiar as an expected moving forward
with exabytes of data that our customers
collect it is becoming more and more
difficult to keep it on premises so they
definitely looking forward to utilize
cloud power to protest the state but
then the situation and security
assurances becoming a little more
fuzzier and more difficult to maintain
because sensitive data is located not
only in one place that they have full
control on premises but also on
different public clouds and what they
understand that they have now shared
responsibility for protect this data so
not only they are in control but also
they need to
sure this responsibility in control with
cloud providers so the situation
becoming a little more complex and as a
result of that there is multiple
questions and challenges that our
customers started to come up with and
trying to address and if I will
summarize what I hear loud and clear
from my customers
there are concerns around very basic
topics like I have plenty of sensitive
data I need to bring it to the cloud how
I will protect it and it's not only
about data they develop significant
amount of IP in their application and
algorithms have to be protected as well
so how I will do that how do I stay
compliant these regulations and all
other rules and auditors requirements
that I have to deal with it because it
was a little bit easier when I control
and to end all my protected data and all
my sensitive data but now when I am
moving this to the cloud it's becoming
more challenging but it's not only
difficulties it's also ability to open a
new very exciting use case if it were
not possible before
for example the keys of all use case of
coverage how will collaborate with so
many companies that I phone to and have
to result in into sure myself sensitive
data in control over that it is all of
them but if some of them maybe even my
competitors and I am not fully trusting
down with my sensitive data how would I
be able to process it together is app
and take advantage on the results of
these collaboration and also very very
important question for all our customers
they are custodians of the date of their
own coins and their own users and
they're going to do their tasks and job
right they want to protect the data
enter so go out with all of those
challenges
is there any magic solution that you
would be able to offer us in fact Nellie
yes we do
we had Google believed that the
protection of sensitive data is
paramount and encryption is a good
mechanism to accomplish this goal we
supported for years encryption in
transit when our customers ingest the
data to bring it to the cloud we also
support encryption at rest so data
stored in the cloud across all services
encrypted data in transit and at rest is
great but it is not sufficient customers
bring the data to GCB for a reason they
want to index it they want to query it
they want to train on it or inferred on
the data for their specific needs so to
complete the data protection lifecycle
you would like to be able to protect
data when it's being processed
confidential computing is a new model
that aims to close this gap confidential
computing means encrypted data in memory
while processing it so with confidential
computing customers get encryption in
use in addition to encryption at rest
and in transit so Nellie let's get to
the point
what are we announcing today yes Gillett
people announced our creation right away
but give me a few more seconds to have
some fun let us dream a little bit what
if this whatever we going to announce
literally right after this single
beautiful chat box you my dear customers
you would be able to encrypt all your
workloads that you ran previously and
again enjoy it so much and make them
confidential simply transform them into
confidential environments what if you
don't need
to pay significant performance and
latency tags of doing this
transformation and what if for some of
you who have to provide audit reports to
the to to your internal and external
auditors you would be able to do it very
easily all of that about your workloads
what if all of that will become reality
and it's exactly what we want to
announce today after some really serious
work that we've done together with our
partners MD we today announcing
confidential VM on an 3d series is it
powered by second generation in the epic
processors in better so Gilad tell us
what is that both is confidential the
arms all about so what is confidential
VM key thing to remember it's just like
a regular VM customers can run any work
load that they usually run in VMs and by
clicking a single check box they will
transform their VMs in to confidential
games when they do that all memory pages
of the confidential DM are encrypted so
you may rightly ask if they're encrypted
how does the CPU process them so data is
encrypted in memory and is decrypted
when it's fetched from memory to the CPU
chip and what about the encryption keys
the keys are generated in Hardware on
the CPU they're ephemeral they're not
persisted anywhere and cannot be
extracted from the CPU chip by anyone
including Google each VM memory is
encrypted by a unique key to that VM and
confidential VMs can scale to meet your
needs
up to 224 virtual CPUs in 896 gigabyte
then
so finally customers can protect the
data end to end from dating transit to
data address and finally to data in use
yes Gilad there's a very how you
describe the key protection is very
important for confidentiality of ability
for us to use
Harvard generated keys is it not
extractable is very very nice property
it means nobody including Google or AMD
will be able to get access to that any
other security capability and Stratton
education ideas is it you believe we
will provide our customers with
confidential DMS well as the name
implies it simply adds confidentiality
while processing data that means the
hypervisor administrators neighbors and
malicious devices cannot snoop your data
while it's in memory as a multi-tenant
cloud provider isolation has always been
a critical component of our
infrastructure
now with confidential computing this
isolation is getting cryptographically
being forced Nelly
can we see a demo of confidential games
I would love to show the demo gilad
thank you so much for asking the first
demo that we don't have today is to
demonstrate to our customers our viewers
how easy is to create confidential avi m
and as we promised initially it would be
simple chat box and you would be able to
transition your normal usual VM to
confidential yeah let me show you how it
can be done so first you coming to a
usual DCP console and you give the name
for confidential VM and you will find a
new chat box literally chat box it will
explain that by clicking this checkbox
your configuration will be sad for yo VR
and all that you would need to do it
simply say create and that's it and
you're confident no the arm is up and
running and to prove to use it it's
confidentiality and let me SSH to this
VM and show it to use it it's running on
a in this server these secure encrypted
virtualization enable and it means all
your memory is going to be encrypted
then it'll process your code or data the
second demo that I want to show you is
slightly different as you remember we
were discussing performance latency and
performance and latency clocks so I want
to demonstrate use it based on what
we've done so far and all testing and
benchmarks we've done we've seen that we
reached the envelope that we were
putting on ourselves not more than 10
percent performance degradation so we've
seen even the results on some of
benchmarks that we've done together this
indeed teams it here somewhere around 2
to 6 percent even better that we
actually put on ourselves but every
single customer need to check please
check your own workload and your own
performance benchmarks to see where you
are but let me show you this quick demo
and the demo is showing you very
interesting grace little half of it'll
have to be arms that build start in the
same home at the same time
non-confidential beyond will come a
little bit later and confidential yeah
but to show you how this tool will
perform first of all let's show use it
on the right side of your screen you
have confidential left side is non
confidential and we will use this badge
the performance tool to validate memory
access memory access is very important
wait for us to check how confident know
the new perform compare non-confidential
and because we're measuring throughput
as you can see comparable is great and
the bigger number is better well done
memory read now we will do memory right
and let's see how these two the arms
will perform and as you can see both of
those films confidential and Allen are
performing very comparable so we didn't
see too much degradation but as I said
please validate your performance results
on your specific workloads and let us
know where you are our announcement of
confidential VMs today is just the first
step we believe that confidential
computing will and should be part of
every Enterprise Cloud point realizing
this ambitious goal requires
collaboration across the entire industry
both cloud providers hardware
manufacturers and software vendors
working together to define standards and
advanced technology this is why Google
was among the founding members of the
confidential computing consortium
operating under the umbrella of the
Linux Foundation together with other key
players like Microsoft Intel AMD arm
Alibaba IBM and many others we are
working together to advance confidence
computing and now I'd like to hear the
perspective of a cloud customers
I'd like to use Morgan from JPMorgan
Chase a lot I want to add one more
interesting tip Morland acres that will
join us right away is also part of
confidence on computing consortium he is
representing customer voice in this
multi industry consortium so it'll be
very interesting to hear from Morgan how
he was doing and what is real learning
he had from working with our original
tree be more than now it's you thank you
very much Nelly I appreciate the
introduction here my name is Morgan
Akers as I mentioned I am a director in
the cybersecurity space inside of JP EMC
and specifically in the data management
and protection organization if you look
at JP MC it's one of the oldest
financial institutions in the world they
work across the geographies and a global
company multiple financial sectors
customers ranging from consumer banking
to corporate services to government
services asset wealth manage
so really they run the gamut in terms of
financial sectors additionally we have a
wide swath of both employees in terms of
different types of roles as well as
customers and so when I think about
managing and protecting our data as a
mission for data management protection
it's really how do we enable data to be
managed correctly and specifically
across the firm seamlessly and without
expertise what I mean by this is as a
user of the data
you shouldn't have to know explicitly
what to do with this data the system
should manage it for you you shouldn't
have to expected to understand that this
said data said it's this sensitivity and
I know how to actually manage the policy
you shouldn't rely on tribal knowledge
this should be something the system
handles for you and when you think about
that seamless and frictionless
experience of managing the data that is
really the pillar that we build on in
terms of maintaining the chain of trust
between our users and our services and
how to use that data
now data management and protection is
really effectively three different
pillars in terms of how we actually
think about our architecture the first
one's classification classification is
really the simplest piece of
understanding what kind of data you're
dealing with who generated it what kind
of data it is sensitivity level is it
business impacting is it critical data
as well as what type of data is it is it
programmatically generated by a service
is it hand authored like an email or
something that's a Word document and how
is it used and where is it coming from
so with that classification of that data
with this fine grained classifications
we can get we move to how we do our
policy decision engines now for every
piece of data based on the
classification we want to create a
policy that says given this type of data
and who's using it what I should do
that's the decision aspect and we really
want to do it from both a build time
perspective as well as a run time and
what I mean by that is that it's not
just when I'm programmatically building
my system in terms of managing the data
as I build my my developer toolkits and
my systems across the financial
institution but also run time for that
real time decision process we're influx
of data comes you need to be able to
make those decisions on the fly and
apply that policy once that policy is
applied and a decision is made you move
to data handling and enforcement which
is essentially what do I do now
is the data encrypted is it do you make
it readable by that individual or that
service is it editable by that reader or
service can you use a token do you need
to decrypt it those are the aspects of
what I would consider data HANA
enforcement so these three things
together form the backbone of what we
think about for data management and
protection
now what
compute as an environment as a what I
would consider an area to to grow and
think about strategically it's still
somewhat in this infancy so our approach
to confidential computing is what do we
think we can use it for that would
inform us of a decision and how do we
then incorporate in our strategy so when
we're looking at our confidential
compute environment one of the things
that we came up with was there's typical
models for user authentication but it's
not as strong in terms of a standard
model for what I would call instance or
host identity models of identification
especially when you're dealing with
multiple providers and multiple systems
and we thought this was ideal for
something that maybe confident it could
be you could solve for so what we think
about is user and incident is it
foundational to us securing sensitive
data who you are who you're working on
behalf of and where it's coming from is
part of that classification aspect as
well as where it should go to if we
build what I call a chain of trust
inside a confidence or compute we can do
effectively this mapping that says all
right service a can talk to service B
and the two together will build that
informational system that understands
what we should do now when I look at how
we manage this there is the customer
manage key that the bank informs us of
and that actually is what we use to
create the authentication requests who
does what and how they actually talk to
the systems and that confidential
compute system is where we're spanning
that mapping so effectively that
managing of the mapping is in the node
of confidence compute it's a user
application or the service and the
resource that's running the application
service and we can use it both out of
the chains that we make as well as the
union of whether you should grant that
handshake or not
now when we think about this this is a a
general pattern of discovery and you can
see by the the the big boxes and arrows
that this is very much a high-level
pattern and it doesn't describe anything
in intimate detail here but what we
really were trying to figure out was if
I create the service instance mapping
and a confident how would that work well
general principles are that the service
a and service B want to actually talk to
each other and so service a would
actually go to our confidence compute
system and say alright get me a
handshake or token and authenticate that
my am this service and I'm an
implementation of the service and I want
to talk to service B the confidential
computing node would actually take the
mapping and say okay service a you are
actually cleared to talk to service B
and here's a one-time token to use with
a time limit on it so we effectively put
a TT on it so it's very short-lived give
it that back to service a service they
presents a service B service B then
presents it back to our trusted system
or in our confidential computing system
and a verified that handshake is real
and it left the to decrypt a request and
it's authenticated what we've done is
we've moved the authentication of this
information about the services away from
being done inside of 308 or service B
it's actually being done in a third
system that and that's confidence to
complete that mal things done and
service a and service you can
concentrate on what they're supposed to
be good at which is their processing
information that reduces the overall
threat matrix in terms of what service a
and service B can do because the mapping
and that verification of credentials is
then being done inside a confidential
compute and as a pattern this is
interesting to us because what it does
is it leverages a lot of the key
infrastructure with services but also it
takes advantage of the idea that
confidential compute is a protected and
closed environment that can manage this
mapping securely
so as I mentioned that previous pattern
that's just a general use case that we
were thinking of an opportunity for
controversy of confidential compute
there's additional things that we think
could be used for in the future
secret storage is one of the key ones
right managing Keys securing those keys
in in its system is it's just a
generally natural fit for confidential
computing the second one is a trust and
integrity chain the previous example
demonstrated a chain of trust with
service and instance mapping but that
can actually be expanded to integrity
chains of who changes the data over time
and what that information has happened
or maybe you have a trusted vendor
relationship across a data set and you
want to understand where that went to
that chain and that management could
actually store it in in terms of
confidence compute another one is a
machine identity now we were talking
about instance identity and
authentication but when I say machine
identity there's actually putting the
materials on the Box themselves
typically that's done with certificates
but what if we actually use confidential
compute to manage the certificates and
the resources of those systems and
there's effectively checking points that
confidential computing system could be
the one that managed certificates and
identities for those post-processing
audit log data no audited on a data a
log data generally they're only as good
as the data that's in them and you
typically need them to be readable and
parsable to be able to make the most of
it creating those events understanding
what happened to chain but with that you
have clear text data that's that could
pose a danger and a threat if we're able
to put that data in clear effectively to
confidential computing systems they can
post process that data get the data out
maybe trigger those events in a secure
way and then dispose of that clear text
data and actually you're just focusing
all the prospects in confidential
compute and then lastly is we call it a
trust and Enclave for data transforms
but really it's just a secure
environment for aggregating data
multiple data sets you want to put
together and and generate queries
searchable indexes and you know
something as simple as even machine
learning if you want to may apply
machine learning or other type of just
go algorithms to data
typically those algorithms need to
operate on the data as in their natural
form if you can actually put that into a
confidential computing environment they
can actually do that processing and you
just worry about the output coming
through and then dispose of it the data
that's inside that confidential
computing node thank you everyone for
watching our show and our nodes mode so
to summarize confidential computing is
an industry-wide
effort critical for securing sensitive
workloads we're focusing on
hardware-based encryption for data use
with a goal of enabling through any
workload of any size our goal is to
offer a customers a no compromise
solution the security you need without
giving up on disability performance the
scale thank you all for joining us today
for this presentation